[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 6 février
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de la
rédaction de tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité locale
les automobilistes circulent sur
l'ouvragé rénové depuis décembre le
nouveau pont schuller a été
officiellement inaugurée hier deux ans
de travaux ont été nécessaires pour
doubler l'édifice qui engendre la
nationale 10 entre la verrière et
maurepas un chantier chiffré à 9
millions d'euros
le grand débat national se poursuit dans
les yvelines à peu un peu plus d'un mois
de la fin de la consultation quelles
premières idées émergent dans le
département le point à suivre et sur
cette thématique toujours elle nous
recevrons fils pleurait d'ufc que
choisir l'association a fait douze
propositions dans le cadre du débat
et puis invité également sur ce plateau
claire maximova dans la tyrannie du
silence cet habitant du généreux
concours raconte son histoire et d abus
sexuels et son viol par un prêtre
lorsqu'elles étaient soeurs carmélites
le chantier avait débuté en 2010 est le
nouveau pont schuller qui relie à
maurepas à la verrière a donc
officiellement été inauguré ce mardi en
présence des élus locaux et de valérie
pécresse le reportage de mickaël millero
cette image était attendue depuis plus
d'une décennie par les habitants de mort
paille de la verrière
les élus locaux ont officiellement
inauguré le nouveau pont schuller ce
mardi 5 février
les travaux qui ont duré deux ans permis
de doubler les voies de circulation sur
un axe emprunté par vingt mille
véhicules chaque jour
aujourd'hui c'est l'aboutissement non
seulement le pont il est efficace
puisqu'il n'y a plus de bouchons
d'entrée d'huile donc c'est un vrai
confort pour l'ensemble des habitants
non seulement de maurepas mossé
d'elancourt c'est une facilité d'accès
non seulement à la gare de la verrière
en bus mais aussi pour ceux qui sont en
voiture qui souhaitent rejoindre la
nationale 10 pour aller travailler
des voies de circulations douces plus
larges ont également été créés pour
relier maurepas à la verrière
bien plus sécuritaire qu'avant les
piétons
bello ont leur propre chemin de cette
manière on va favoriser aussi j'espère
un déplacement
sans vainqueur coût total de l'opération
9 millions d'euros prise en charge à
hauteur de 30% par 50 en yvelines et à
70% par le département l'état et la
région
nous l'avons fait parce que nous
considérons composer la route aux
transports en commun c'est une
aberration c'est sur la route qu'on va
faire rouler le les futurs transport en
site propre qui relieront la verrière et
rap
et c'est sur ces ponts en imitant les
embouteillages que on arrive à limiter
la pollution et limiter le stress
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur ce
nouveau pont schuller une exposition
retraçant l'histoire du projet a été
mise en place à la sortie de la gare de
la verrière et après le pont schuller
c'est aussi celui de la vie dieu qui
devraient être rénovés et doublé il
enjambe également la nationale 10
quelques kilomètres plus loin entre
elles en cours et la verrière valérie
pécresse a promis l'inscription de ce
projet au prochain contrat de plan
etat-région une réhabilitation qui se
chiffrerait à 30 millions d'euros
transport toujours mais sur rails la
présidente de la région francilienne l'a
confirmé à notre micro la ligne n aura
bien deux nouveaux trains en circulation
sur l'axé saint quentin rambouillet est
d'ici la fin 2021 c'était la promesse de
son plan de renouvellement du matériel
roulant et des rames neuves seront dans
un premier temps à déployer sur paris et
la petite couronne cette année
au total ce sont 69 nouveaux trains qui
seront mises en place et puis il
permettra de relier la gare de l'est à
paris à l'aéroport roissy charles de
gaulle en 20 minutes le cdg express
verra bien le jour annonce hier de la
ministre des transports elisabeth borne
est les délais d'une livraison avant les
jo 2000 24 sont intenables et ne se
feront pas au détriment et des
transports du quotidien notamment du rer
b a affirmé la ministre
un trajet de 32 km qui coûtera aux
passagers 24 euros depuis le 15 janvier
le grand débat national animent la vie
politique aux quatre coins de l'hexagone
bonsoir nicolas landry concert grégory
alors dans les yvelines le grand débat
s'est mise en place avec notamment
plusieurs réunions organisées et des
réunions aussi à venir alors comment se
déroule cette consultation depuis
presque un mois sur le territoire
alors ce sont des rendez-vous à
l'initiative des maires des
parlementaires d'associations ou encore
de citoyens sous différentes formes avec
des réunions publiques comme on le voit
ici
à poissy et des interventions à tour de
rôle entre les citoyens des débats se
crée au sein de ces réunions publiques
et un autre forme os et attrapes avec
des ateliers de réflexion comme on le
voit sur ces images avec des tables
rondes et d'une synthèse à la fin sur
chaque thématique justement les
thématiques elles ont été annoncées par
le président de la république dans sa
lettre
donc je les rappelle un fiscalité et
dépense publique organisation de l'état
démocratie et citoyenneté ou encore
transition écologique mais des
propositions peuvent être faites aussi
sur des thèmes ouvert alors justement
quelles propositions ont été faites par
ses citoyens quelle première proposition
est bien grégory on retrouve plusieurs
propositions émises par des citoyens
participant à ces débats notamment sur
les questions fiscales qui reviennent
souvent comme la remise en place de
l'impôt sur la fortune le fameux isf une
réforme sur l'impôt sur le revenu avec
par exemple le paiement de l'impôt dès
le premier euro gagné ou encore la tva à
taux zéro sur certains produits
autre thématique c'est les institutions
la reconnaissance du vote blanc le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne où la
baisse du salaire des parlementaires
enfin le renforcement de la
décentralisation revient souvent avec
plus de pouvoir confier aux
collectivités voilà quelques idées parmi
d'autres quand vous l'avez dit des
réunions ont déjà été organisées quel
est le programme des prochaines réunions
de ce grand débat national
mais c'est un programme assez riche et
dense jusqu'au 15 mars prochain
regardez ces infographies toutes les
communes de saint quentin en yvelines
ont prévu des rendez vous villepreux
organise quatre réunions pour quatre
thématiques
même situation pour voisins le
bretonneux qui regroupe les thèmes deux
par deux à elancourt de réunions sont
prévues dont celle du 22 février qui est
celle-ci organisé par leiji les jeunes
des yvelines
autre débat l'initiative du député
didier baichère consacrée aux jeunes
yvelinois au lycée d'hôtellerie et de
tourisme de guyancourt maurepas ou
encore coignières ont aussi leur rendez
vous est maintenant si on prend d'autres
communes des yvelines
on retrouve des débats sur l'ensemble du
territoire on voit fontenay le fleury
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines versailles le
mesnil saint denis ou encore bois d'arcy
la queue-lez-yvelines chevreuse et
rambouillet cette liste bien sûr n'est
pas exhaustive d'autres réunions sont
prévues dans le département
pour plus de d'information pardon vous
pouvez vous rendre sur le site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran ou
contacter directement votre mairie merci
nicolas pour ces précisions on continue
justement à parler du grand débat
national avec vous philippe le ray
bonsoir soit d'être le président du ufc
que choisir est région de versailles
alors l'association de consommateurs au
niveau national à l'occasion de ce grand
débat a lancé sa contribution des
consommateurs 12 mesures pour améliorer
le pouvoir d'achat des français
avec ces mesures 9 milliards d'euros
pourrait être dégagée pour les ménages
sans surcoût pour les finances publiques
or le vrai pour le pouvoir d'achat des
français c'est pas une chose nouvelle
pour l'association ça fait déjà
plusieurs années qu'elle travaille sur
le sujet oui tout à fait voilà déjà
plusieurs années que nous intervenons
régulièrement dans ce domaine et là
l'occasion nous est donnée donc de faire
valoir nos propositions et donc à
travers une grande consultation des
consommateurs de tous les consommateurs
et de faire des propositions donc pour
renforcer le pouvoir d'achat des
français pourquoi le faire au moment de
ce grand débat c'est un peu à la mode en
ce moment de faire remonter ces
revendications
ces propos de l'ufc que choisir c'est
l'association de consommateurs la plus
importante de france donc il est tout à
fait logique nous intervenir dans ce
grand débat alors il ya douze mesures
qui ont été proposées avec plusieurs
thèmes on va les présenter dans un
instant alors le premier thème de ce
grand débat c'est vous voulez le mettre
en avant au travers de cette action
c'est il faut parler pouvoir d'achat
dans ce grand débat c'est le premier
thème c'est à dépenser moins parce que
wade pouvoir d'achat ya deux solutions
c'est soit gagner plus ou dépenser moins
nous
examinons les mesures pour dépenser
moins donc sur ce pouvoir d'achat on l'a
dit 12 mesures notamment sur
l'alimentation alors l'une des mesures
avancées par ufc que choisir c'est
d'annuler par exemple le relèvement du
seuil de la revente à perte instaurée
par la loi alimentation la loi qui est
entrée en vigueur au 1er février
ça gonfle la facture des consommateurs
mais ça gonfle aussi le lait les marges
pardon de la grande distribution
oui on estime que en annulant sept cette
mesure dont nous étions déjà fermement
opposé au printemps dernier lors du vote
cela permettrait aux consommateurs de
récupérer environ 800 millions d'euros
luxe qui est pas neutre
alors pourquoi cette mesure que vous le
savez donc elle permet à la grande
distribution de mettre en place des
marges
la loi autorise des marges saisir de 10%
sur les grands produits d'appel de la dé
la grande distribution il n'est plus
possible de vendre donc en dessous d'une
marge de 10% ce qui contribue donc à
augmenter les prix donc au détriment des
consommateurs
donc c'est premier thème de
l'alimentation ailleurs aussi les
banques qui sont dans le viseur alors
vous prêt que préconisé par don head et
de supprimer les commissions
d'intervention en cas d'incident
bancaire c'est-à-dire supprimé en somme
les les frais quand on est à découvert
avec cette mesure
ufc que choisir chiffre à 2,8 milliards
d'euros qui pourrait revenir directement
aux ménages avec la saisir oui tout à
fait ça fait très très important bon
beaucoup de français la plupart moment
eu d un jour ou l'autre des incidents
bancaires et malheureusement donc chaque
fois ghanassia bancaire il y à une
sanction financière
donc constaté par le titulaire du compte
avec un prélèvement donc sur son relevé
de compte et c'est une sanction est donc
que finalement on estime qu'il revient
faire de la prévention et non pas punir
et aggraver encore la situation
financière difficile de certains
français donc c'est pour ça qu'on
demande la suppression de cette mesure
dans cette mesure a été abordé par le
président de la république lors du grand
débat à evry courcouronnes l'encadrement
des loyers ufc que choisir souhaite
l'encadrement de ses loyers dans les
zones dites tendues
il ya une expérimentation qui a été
rendu facultatif par la loi est lent et
il est possible partout d'encadrer ces
loyers ces motifs voilà il faut voir
mais ce que ce que nous demandons s'ils
voulaient c'est qu'on utilise
l'expérience ce que l'on constate c'est
que il y à un encadrement qui est fait à
paris et à lille avec de bons résultats
donc pourquoi se priver de ces bons
résultats et ne pas étendre cette
possibilité à d'autres communes ou des
difficultés effectivement au niveau des
loyers dans le domaine de la santé
deux mesures principales limites et les
dépassements d honoraires médicaux il ya
aussi une mesure de faciliter la
comparaison est le changement d
assurance santé
oui alors il faut parler de
complémentaire santé pourquoi on s'est
aperçu que le montant des cotisations
des complémentaires santé a augmenté de
50% en disant que ces dix dernières
années c'est que ce qui est considérable
considérables et donc que ce que l'on
souhaite c'est que il y ait une facilité
pour les français de changer de mutuelle
ce qui permettrait donc de faire des
économies très importantes pour les
français une dernière mesure qu'on n'a
pas le temps d'évoquer sur l'automobile
en tout cas c'est de là qu'est partie la
contestation des gilets jaunes et la
réponse de ce grand débat national
vous souhaitez favoriser l'émergence
d'auto-école en ligne c'est-à-dire voit
la facilité en tout cas l'apprentissage
de la conduite donc ça c'est l'une des
mesures
je voulais vous demander pour terminer
donc toutes ces mesures on peut voter
pour les trois meilleures mesures sur le
site de que choisir c'est ça
donc il suffit d'aller sur deux
si tu arrives sur le site qu'elle
choisit repreneur s'affiche cache misère
alors voilà et donc à travers les deux
mesures proposé d'en retenir 3 est donc
ce soir ces trois mesures que nous
porterons dogues dans le grand débat est
donc ces mesures sur quechoisir.org à
retrouver merci philippe acteurs et de
n'être pas c'est sur ce plateau
président du ufc que choisir région de
versailles
on vous en parlait lundi de nombreuses
possibilités de formation existent sur
le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines notamment depuis 2010 est la
possibilité de suivre un cursus au sein
du campus du numérique parmi l'offre
proposée l'école simplon ouverte à
elancourt nicolas d'ombrie programmés ou
codées un jeu de dominos le projet sur
lequel travaillent les 23 prenant de la
promotion développeurs web de l'école
simplon avec un esprit d'entraidé entre
les personnes formées des profils
différents avec plus ou moins
d'expérience dans le numérique on
démarre à partir d'une page vide et ont
créé le code en entier ce qui nous donne
un rendu qu'on peut visualiser
directement on fait des tutoriaux pour
sa prendre les uns aux autres ce que
sont les notions de javascript
je voulais compléter mon expérience de
graphistes développeurs web et dans le
domaine de la communication pour être
une professionnelle complète
je pense que les intervenants en c est
lui très bien les cours je comprends
parfaitement les apprenants viennent
d'horizons différents le plus jeune a 20
ans et le plus âgé 52 ans porté par
saint quentin en yvelines simple on
accueille aussi 20 apprenants dans une
promotion de développeurs date à une
table une base de données relationnelle
de clients de produits et de
transactions ce qui implique des
factures des transactions et ainsi de
suite
on s'est parlé en fait des différentes
bases de données
quand on reçoit des données par exemple
on commence dans une nouvelle boîte ils
ont plein de plein de donner du style
des clients des noms de clients des
adresses etc
il faut tout simplement les mettant un
tableur histoire que ce soit plus clair
trier faciles à retrouver
potentiellement rechargeable
35 heures de formation par semaine du
lundi au vendredi sur sept mois avec à
la clé un diplôme équivalent bac + 2 un
formateur pour chacune des promotions et
une pédagogie proactive pour les
apprenants
le but c'est pour chaque apprenant oda
prenantes
c'est de s'autoformer donc ils sont en
groupe il travaille trés principalement
toujours en mode projet ça veut dire que
de trouver la ressource par eux mêmes
dans un premier temps à la fin de la
formation prévue le 31 juillet ils
seront considérés comme des développeurs
juniors une deuxième promotion et déjà
prévu les dates ne sont pas encore
déterminées une déclaration inédite du
pape françois le souverain pontife a
reconnu hier que des prêtres et des
évêques avaient agressé sexuellement des
religieuses un phénomène qui se
rencontre partout selon lui sur lequel
l'église affirme-t-il travaille depuis
longtemps un livre justement lève le
voile sur ces problèmes d'agressions
sexuels au sein de l'église
la tyrannie du silence s'est sorti en
janvier aux éditions cherche midi
le témoignage d'une ancienne carmélites
abusé sexuellement et violée par un
prêtre c'est votre histoire claire
maximova bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
pour cet entretien alors vous êtes
aujourd'hui professeur d'anglais
habitante du chéné rocancourt
je précise qu'au cours de cet entretien
on ne pourra ni citer de noms de
personne ni de lieu puisque deux
affaires elles sont en cours au pénal
est également un procès canonique une
première question pourquoi avoir eu
envie de témoigner sur ce qui vous est
arrivé
parce que ce qui m'est arrivé c'est très
difficile à vivre et ça m'a pris
beaucoup d'années nous coûte et ont à
vivre avec ces poids des culpabilités
qui n'est pas le mien et parce que au
bout de ces quelques années j'ai
découvert les livres par exemple aider
muriel salmona où j'ai lu la description
des réactions des victimes des violences
et ça poser des mots sur ce que j'ai
vécu et je me suis dit si moi je n'ai
parlé pendant six mois je ne portais pas
cette parole aux victimes qui n'ont pas
fait des découvertes et que moi j'ai
fait qu'il le ferait et donc c'est pour
libérer la parole pour permettre aux
autres victimes des maîtres et les monde
sur ce qu'est leur est arrivé que ses
livres alors parlons de votre histoire
claire maximova vous convertissez au
catholicisme à 15 ans en 98 2 vous
entrée au carmel à l'âge de 24 ans vous
êtes alors la plus jeune soeur au sein
de ce qu armel et c'est un moment
compliqué pour vous vous vivez un moment
compliqué oui c'était un moment assez
difficile et et stabilisant parce que
c'était pas le monastère pour lequel
j'ai eu le coup de foudre en celui pour
lequel j'ai roulé entre il était fermé
un peu quand je suis arrivé et je
déclarer ma flamme et les surnoms dit
qu'elle fermait donc je me suis retrouvé
dans un autre monastère où placer la
plus jeune avait l'âge de ma mère et les
autres et l'âge de ma grand-mère et plus
si au niveau des dents tant des
mutuelles au niveau des différences de
mentalité c'était vraiment très
difficile d'autant plus que j'avais né
des parois c'est qu'ils étaient très
vivante
il y avait beaucoup de convertis et
l'ambiance était très différente dans
dans cette solitude quelques années plus
tard vous fait la rencontre d'un prêtre
il a 80 plus que vous vous trouvez en
lui un confident un grand frère
spirituel vous aviez besoin de ce grand
frère
à cette époque j'avais besoin d'aidé
comment faire a déjà enfin j'ai rêvé
d'avoir un frère et depuis que j'étais
tout petit
et puis quand j'ai eu l'appel au calme
livre d intérêt ce délicieux qui
s'appelle est l'histoire d'une âme et
j'ai découvert qu'elle avait aussi deux
frères spirituel et pour moi c'était une
évidence qu'un jour ou l'autre le
seigneur me donnera un frère et il est
arrivé assez rapidement après ma
profession solennelle est assez
longtemps on a une relation très
spirituel on a échangé des lettres on a
échangé sur sur notre vécu au carmel à
la con une mauvaise tournure cette
relation à sa prime mauvaise tournure à
un moment donné parce qu'on était au
parloir et
ça derrière un peu il a essayé de
m'embrasser donc à ces moments là nous
avons pris distance moi j'avais toujours
besoin des sonneurs d'après ce que j'ai
j'ai commencéà comptait vraiment sur lui
et j'étais absolument et puis c est
dévastée à ces moments là dans ce
comportement déplacé à votre égard vous
en parlait d'ailleurs autour de vous en
parler à son supérieur spirituel qu'est
ce qu'on vous reste à ces pères
spirituels pardon qu est ce qu on vous
répond à ce moment là bas il m'a dit
directement que j'ai fait en un frère
spirituel beaucoup de mal parce que j'ai
les dévoyer ddd son don à dieu et que
c'est ma faute parce qu'il fallait qu'il
vivait son don à dieu complètement non
vous l'avez dit vous aviez besoin de ce
grand frère spirituel après vous être
éloigné un temps vous finissez par
renouer contact et là il va aller plus
loin des gestes de plus en plus des
places et ça ça va se terminer par par
un viol oui en fait c sté sapri encore
quelques années avant que ça arrive
jusqu'à lâcher comme je me suis
effondrée complètement parce que j'avais
aucune en tunnel et aucun soutien et en
plus ce qu'il avait fait était retournée
contre moi ce qui m a complètement
démoli parce que si quelqu'un savait
quelque chose sur mon appel pour la vie
religieuse c'était lui il en connaissait
autant que moi et il le fait qu'il
retourne contre moi mes confidences
qu'il retourne contre moi la culpabilité
je ne comprenais rien et dont quelques
années plus tard je suis sorti du carmel
eshèté donc j'ai commencé à travailler
tout au tout en étant le tout en n'ayant
mes voeux valide et cherchons comment
trouver ma place dans l'église au temps
consacré et il restait le
seul prêtre hawkish j'aurais pu
m'adresser parce que tous les autres à
qui j'ai demandé de l'aide
on pris des distances avec moi et quand
elle a su que j'étais tout seul et que
je travaille et il a dit qu'il allait
venir
et ça continue et environs au début donc
jusqu'à jusqu'à ce violent que vous
allez bien sûr dénoncé auprès de son
père spirituel là vous allez vous
heurtez encore une nouvelle fois c'est
qu'à cette heure cette fois ci c'était
pense on espère spirituel c'est qu'elles
sont supérieurs qui sont supérieures
d'accord et vous allez vous heurtez
encore une nouvelle fois cette tyrannie
du silence que vous dénoncez c'était en
fait la première fois que j'en ai parlé
et j'étais temps je mettais pas le mont
violent l'a déçu parce que pour moi
comme pour la plupart des gens tout au
moins jusqu'à 7h takemitsu jusqu'à
maintenant le gueule ça devait se
produire normalement à la rue dans la
nuit avec quelqu'un que tu ne connais
pas le couteau à la gorge ou une arme et
là c'était quelqu'un que j'ai croyez
connaître parce qu'elles ont échangé
quand même au niveau spirituel des
années et il s'est présenté comme un
pauvre être plein de répartie repentir
il me demandait pardon à chaque fois et
l'image que j'avais de lui ce n'était
pas un pervers narcissique ce que j'ai
j'allais découvrir plus tard en lisant
les livres
c'était un être qui est très très faible
et qui est très blessée dans son enfance
et qui avait besoin de l'indicé pour
pour qu'elles sont supérieurs lui
accorder l'aide que j'ai
j'ai les notifier et enfin rien laisser
passer ce que j'allais apprendre
beaucoup plus tard vous avez appris par
la suite que votre cas n'est pas unique
tout ça est oui j'ai appris que mon camp
n'était pas unique que dans cet ordre
il ya d'autres religieux qui ont abusé
d'aider plusieurs personnes et il y a
six femmes même globalement dans
l'église il y a beaucoup plus des cas
que ce que j'aurais pu imaginer
dans le pire des cauchemars c'est un
phénomène d'ailleurs qui a reconnu je le
disais en début d'entretien le pape
hier il a affirmé que des religieuses
ont été abusées sexuellement par des
prêtres que c'était un vrai problème qui
existait au sein l'église est ce que par
cette déclaration vous avez l'impression
que les choses avancent en tout cas
évolué sur sur le domaine ou pas du tout
en fait et si on me regardait déjà les
les choses et au niveau des paies des
filets
je ne trouve pas qu'il ya quelque chose
qui avance vraiment il ya les
déclarations et au niveau des des actes
devrait des actes concrets
je vois très très peu donc j'ai je vois
des paroles mais je vois pas d'acte en
est au niveau des religieuses c'est un
bon signe que le pape s'est exprimé là
dessus maintenant j'ai vraiment besoin
dé voir quelque chose qui bouge parce
que mon agresseur jusqu'à maintenant et
il est prieur pas pas uniquement qu'il
n'a aucune aucune sanction n'a été ni le
lien brisé mais été imposé mais même au
niveau des mesures conservatoires
il y a rien qui s'est mis en place avec
les choses avancent peut-être aussi vous
disiez en début d'entretien que la
parole se libère que d'autres religieuse
peut être victime aussi de ce genre
d'acte témoigne moi je doute un an
nettement j'ai tout inquiète d'autres
religieuse commencerons à parler pour la
simple raison que j'ai c'est qu'elle
peut être est la pression de la part des
supérieurs moi je ne suis plus cette
pression dont personne ne peut me dire
tu es toi c'est une côte et d'autre part
il y a le fait que avant que ma parole
se libère
j'ai eu quand même des lectures jeux
c'était par exemple et le livre de
muriel salmona que normalement vous ne
trouvez pas dans la bibliothèque est en
cours et je ne sais pas il faudrait
vraiment la volonté des supérieurs pour
donner à leurs religieuse ces genres et
des lectures pour qu'elles puissent
faire leur chemin
donc je ne pense pas que l'avalanche des
révélations ça va se produire des mains
même si j'ai quelques raisons de penser
que c'est beaucoup plus répondu que ce
que j'avais pensé avant dernière
question très rapidement est ce que ce
calvaire que vous avez vécu ce que ça
remis en cause de votre foi mot forme
dieu non parce qu'elle ce qu'il avait
fait dans ma vie c'est je ne peut pas
l'effacer je peux pas l'expliquer
autrement que par son intervention j'ai
vécu aussi des choses très très belle
dans l'église catholique
en revanche c'est vrai que
je les trouve un peu comme une personne
qui nagent à côté de titanic et gêné
sait pas quoi faire parce que j'ai quand
j'ai découvert l'ampleur de cette
corruption chez mon image à l'image de
l'église que j'avais il est complètement
perturbé il est complètement changé et
j'ai comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure je
ne vois pas d acte réel des actes
concrets qui sont posées donc j'essuie
on a compté pour voir ce que quelques
elle sert à ma place dans l'église et
pour la suite merci car maximova pour ce
témoignage la tyrannie du silence c'est
aux éditions du cherche midi est
disponible au prix de 17 euros et pour
refermer ce journal l'heure de notre
petit tour dans les salles de cinéma du
territoire comme chaque mercredi
ce soir c'est le grenier à sel qui se
prêtent au jeu le grenier à sel de
trappes pour présenter le programme du
moment c'est au micro de patrick jacques
de dixmude
[Musique]
nous connaissons tous guéris qu
aujourd'hui il vient d'avoir 20 ans ce
compte est toujours aussi charmant
humaniste et donc les enfants
d'aujourd'hui doivent absolument le
découvrir et les enfants d'hier doivent
absolument le voir ou le revoir sur
grand écran
souvenez vous un peu l'histoire à peine
sorti du ventre de sa mère il parlait
court plus vite que le commun des
mortels mais il est aussi très malin et
il incarne le courage et la persévérance
dans ce film la frontière entre le bien
et le mal n'est pas si évidente et c'est
ça le message fondamental du film la
source de la naissance t est bien
souvent la souffrance et un retour en
arrière est possible mais pour ça il
faut bien sûr aller à la rencontre de
l'autre et le comprendre pour sublimer
ce compte
michel ocelot a utilisé le dessin
traditionnel pain sur papier la faune et
la flore y sont très riches
d'ailleurs les décors sont ouvertement
inspiré du douanier rousseau la musique
composée par youssou ndour ce film peut
être vu à partir de 4 ans mais certaines
scènes sont impressionnantes pour les
plus jeunes comme les apparitions
théâtrales de la sorcière ou les animaux
sauvages
je conseille donc ce film pour les
enfants à partir de 5 ans retrouvez
kirikou et la sorcière au cinéma le
grenier à sel
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal dans un
instant nouveau numéro du 7-8 débat
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]